Dutch tolerant Dutch beautiful country
fair is fair
only the Netherlands
I think people here are too few
have too little thing
so too little character
it really is
it was laughing
what is where i think character here in the netherlands
I am very much shaped by the media
and a little blank by everyone
is that that character
that culture is missing
I don't think that culture is that strong
lots of sheep
i think that culture is not that strong
that you say no listen
these are our standards
these are our values
here we give for
you can find something today
that father is going to watch TV tomorrow or another opinion tomorrow
he comes no you know what
we also participate
yes she is going to talk all over again
someone has a very nice value
that just fine stuff
that can be easily linked to our norms and values
just name a few then you are thinking
I ask the question myself
healthcare system in the Netherlands
but that's one on one
how we have Islamic norms and values
how to deal with the sick
we are in a fucking beautiful country man
act normal dude
everything is completely under control here man
autistic landscape and we live in legoland